I don't know what to say really three
minutes till the biggest battle of our
professional lives all comes down to
today either we heal as a team we're
gonna crumble inch by inch play by play
till we're finished we're in Hell right
now gentlemen believe me and we can stay
here get that kicked out of us or we can
fight our way back into the light we can
climb out of hell one inch at a time now
I can't do it for you I'm too old I look
around I see these young faces and I
think I mean I made every wrong choice a
middle-aged man can make
I uh that's the way all my money believe
it or not I chased off anyone who's ever
loved me and lately I can't even stand
the face I see in America you know when
you get old in life things get taken
from that's that's that's part of life
but you only learn that when you start
losing stuff you find out life's this
game of inches
you saw his football because in either
game life or football the margin for
error is so small I mean one half a step
too late or too early and you don't
quite make it one half second too slow
too fast you don't quite catch it the
inches we need are everywhere around us
they're in every break of the game every
minute every second
on this team we fight for that inch on
this team we tear ourselves and everyone
else around us to pieces for that inch
with our fingernails
because we know when we add up all those
inches that's gonna make the difference
between winning and losing
and yes in any fight it's the guy who's
willing to die who's gonna win that itch
and I know if I'm gonna have any life
it's because I'm still willing to fight
and die for that edge that's what living
is the six inches in front of your face
now I can't make you do it you gotta
look at the guy next year look into his
eyes now I think you're gonna see a guy
who will go to that inch with hell yeah
you're gonna see a guy who will
sacrifice himself for this team because
he knows when it comes down to it you're
gonna do the same for him that's a team
gentlemen and either we heal now as a
team or we will die as individuals
that's football guys
that's all it is
now
what are you gonna do
you